[Música]
bienvenido a 5 minutos con hoy nos
acompaña el doctor enrique casalino él
es peruano pero también es el director
de urgencias del hospital universitario
villa uno de los más importantes de
parís es que está viviendo obviamente en
primera línea el kobe 19 buenos días
doctor cómo están buenos días
usted trabaja aquí en las urgencias no
cierto cuéntenos cómo es en tiempos de
estamos en una tercera ola hemos tenido
una hora en la primavera última hemos
tenido una ola al comienzo del invierno
del otoño el invierno y ahora tenemos
una tercera ola que afecta el hospital
porque los equipos están cansados hay un
efecto de saturación el modelo de la ola
ha sido diferente las primeras olas
fueron realmente un pico la primera la
segunda un poquito menos y esta tercera
es más bien una un ascenso progresivo
lento pero permanente del número de
casos y eso hace que el hospital se
satura y que estemos todos mucho más
cansados ustedes
incluso maneja los números del personal
que tiene que poner a disposición de un
paciente de kobe y de un paciente de
otra enfermedad mucho más grande no ese
es una de nuestras dificultades mayores
un paciente cobit consume dos a tres
veces más personal que un paciente no
cobit porque hay que vestirse cambiarse
de vestirse asegurar un número de de una
separación entre las camas para que no
contaminemos a los pacientes en el
hospital entonces es una dificultad para
poder aumentar el número de camas de uci
y el número de camas covite en el
hospital estamos obligados de cerrar
muchas más camas en los sectores no kobe
que le parece a ustedes las medidas que
tomar el gobierno ha sido muy criticado
por su lentitud le parece que ahora hay
medidas más restrictivas concretamente
se prohíben los movimientos entre
regiones en este nuevo confinamiento y
en todo el país porque hasta hace pocas
semanas no ciertos estábamos solamente
19 departamentos con restricciones y el
resto seguía viviendo entre comillas de
manera normal hay varias maneras de
mirarlo todo depende cuál es el objetivo
que nos damos
en el sistema de salud estamos sumamente
saturados tanto en las regiones donde ya
había una epidemia fuerte que en las
regiones entre las entre comillas le
pide me es un poco más lenta pero
sabemos que es más lenta ahora pero que
va a seguir progresando
por eso número uno estamos de acuerdo de
que se haya generalizado las medidas de
restricción del movimiento de la
población y las medidas de confinamiento
se han aumentado eso a nivel nacional
parece lógico hubiésemos preferido y yo
personalmente hubiese preferido unas
medidas más fuertes de restricción para
poder disminuir de manera muy importante
el número de casos de kobe y la
necesidad de camas que se anunció en
medicina el gobierno ha preferido
favorecer una actividad económica una
interacción social lo que puedo
comprender pero no va a ser suficiente
creo que no va a ser suficiente para
proteger el sistema de salud doctor y
otra cosa que comienza en francia es la
vacunación masiva a través de estos
centros vacuno dromo ha estado lento
francia
en la vacunación a qué se debe y esto
podría cambiar la situación que se está
viviendo el problema de logístico es en
la parte inicial de la logística es la
fabricación de las vacunas y la
disposición de las vacunas en francia
ese es el elemento principal por ejemplo
marruecos ha vacunado a más personas que
francia porque marruecos ha ido a
comprar las vacunas a china chile ha
vacunado más personas que francia
proporcionalmente porque han comprado
las vacunas en el exterior en francia la
decisión europea ha sido que la
comunidad económica europea compre las
vacunas para todos los países europeos y
cada uno individualmente no puede ir y
comprar vacunas al vecino a otro país
eso ha sido probablemente un error
estratégico al mismo tiempo hay un
mensaje muy importante no hay que pensar
que la vacunación de la población es lo
que va a proteger la población la
vacunación de la población va a proteger
el día que hayamos vacunado 80% de la
población de nuestro país para vacunar
80% de la población y partir del
principio que no vamos a vacunar a los
niños quiere decir que vamos a vacunar
prácticamente a todos los adultos
para llegar a ese objetivo necesitamos
varios meses los países que han reducido
la mortalidad gracias a la vacunación e
inglaterra por ejemplo el gracias a la
vacunación y a un confinamiento
sumamente estricto sentido israel es el
mismo fenómeno en chile es el
contraejemplo chile vacunado bastante
pero en contrapartida no ha tenido una
política de confinamiento
suficientemente fuerte y por eso es que
no hay una reducción de la mortalidad
muchas gracias doctor enrique casalino y
ustedes sigan con la programación
habitual de france 24